list springing c'est quand Berkeley
joins us on loan from the New York
Giants a Quan good to talk to you again
how are you I'm blonde girl how we done
where are you right now
I earned the New Jersey in the home in
New Jersey right now do you have a
backyard to work out in I have a
backyard at a gym set up downstairs all
the transparency and then is somebody
there to help work you out like what do
you do to stay in shape what would you
normally be doing and can you do that at
home I mean I'm very fortunate enough to
be able to do exactly that I will be
doing which would be going to it
security home and will come out and then
doing work I was doing only thing I
can't do
go to say I have a lot of equipment
downstairs in my in my basement to do
the readout and on my female grant Harry
England Congress been going through you
know my trainers workout friend from
Nike and also the workouts are giant
something do you know what the Giants
are going to do with their pick in the
first round
this could be an offensive tackle you
have to know more than I do say Quan I
just try to come every single day now
which is virtually and we try to prepare
myself as best I can and I just know
attend me we're gonna come in and you
know kind of have the same answer we
later your again I'm gonna hope you see
me again
yeah but okay let me make you the GM
just for the moment who would you like
to bring in like what position would you
like to have when you need to line hell
you need to tackle you know yeah right I
would say you know there's a need
it's not it's not the only one position
you know that's going like this
turn around come little Johnson you know
I know the BG and all them guys play a
lot of their game and the decisions are
they make no you're saying all the right
things they don't need a quarterback and
they don't need a running back with the
Giants but they they could use some help
elsewhere what did you think when you
saw Christian McCaffrey get paid oh um
happy I know do you think has been more
social no I mean I would really say the
Christian he was able to play respect
you know respect respect a lot of them
fouling yards and rushing at the I was
feeling very play that would be a become
the highest-paid one today it's truly
amazing and I'm truly second yeah but
you're also saying that's where my
negotiations start right not really
because I mean this is how I just
operate with a lot of things the other
negotiations contract money or anything
I'm a big believer is you got take care
of everything face and I couldn't let go
soon the day I would try to be that
female can be in the best rapper in the
best version myself I mean taking a list
of all the big names make okay so yeah
well once again once you're negotiating
your contract you're gonna say let's
start with what Christian is making and
then we'll add on to that that's what
I'm gonna guess you know I can handle
this for you if you want me to yeah you
gonna be good cop bad cop you'll be the
good cop everybody loves you great
personality good teammate I'll be the
bad guy and I'll go in there and say we
started that number we start where
Christian McCaffrey left off and then
you know the s in say Kwan is going to
be a dollar sign when I'm done with it
what do you think that's fine that's
fine
did you when did you know okay that's
all I do is give sake one when did you
know the Giants were going to take you
with that number two overall pick
and the eating ban said rather the day I
went up there I became involved in
selecting Baker mixer and then within
couple seconds that's when you knew Wow
I would have thought that they told you
prior to that with a were they concerned
you couldn't keep a secret or something
oh well I mean to be honest with in the
works of being injected concerts in
between states and Alize in Macomb know
I am a food addict we're in New York
they're gonna be fair I'm um apparently
ratandas very milk for the ferryman
paparazzi opportunity for me and my
family and I said sighs there's a very
mythology remember and then this be able
to come back to the island burn and be
like okay and there was concerns I am
armed and by the help I brought them of
that so definitely definitely wait goose
you thought the Browns we're going to
take you perhaps number one overall tell
you that they were gonna take you number
one did they tell you that they have
taken you number one overall say Quan
Barclay that's s with the dollar sign
the Giants running back joining us on
behalf of fedex.com slash coronavirus
let the audience know
you're doing how they can get involved
huge dependence second sentence Lebanon
and then today I'm here with under the
hack aesthetics and he's having them
over there and a fight against other
nursing and David admin I'll talk to you
later
- Connecticut - I could have the right
company a community delivering another
spear million loss as a million pieces
of heavy equipment which is I know
systematically left the loose and the
keep up to date with the FedEx relief
efforts because it's good to talk to you
be safe and enjoy the draft tonight
that's sick Juan Berkeley Giants